my husband um spends on average about
$1,000 a month um at gas
stations um for you know snacks drinks
um a majority of that though is for
chewing tobacco he goes through maybe
two to three cans a day and that can be
pretty pricey and my question um is how
can I help him
become how can I help him work towards
becoming more financially responsible
with addiction it's not as simple as
saying hey we're going to we're going to
cut them off I think it starts with this
conversation of you going listen this is
going to deteriorate your health I want
you around to see our kids grow up I
want us to actually hit our financial
goals it's derailing us financially for
you to be spending this way and by the
way gas stations are one of the worst
places to buy all of this stuff it's the
highest cost